I knew this was what happened. He's so full of man. He is so
full of dog. No evidence of adultery.
>> He might come out looking really bad. From what I understand,
she had no access to any of their accounts. Man, now I want to
look further into this cuz I think this is just like a total
lie.
>> NMPLoL
putting out a video called the truth about my divorce. Now, if
you guys
NMP was in a divorce with his long-term wife, his long-term girlfriend
and wife, Malena. I forget her last name. Tudi or something?
Malena Tudi.
And he sought more than 50% of the marital assets. And I think
there are a couple reasons for that. I think she was worried
that he was overspending money on his own. And so she sought
I think she was seeking 55, 45, or 60/40, okay?
And I mean, you know, it is what it is. I thought she had some
okay arguments for that.
And I thought that he was also seemingly seemed to be hiding
some assets from her based on the documents that were filed,
okay? And I guess now, here's his final thing, the truth about
my divorce. He's going to come out and say exactly what happened.
He was very upset, if you guys remember, at Henry Resilient.
Henry Resilient would get his court documents and publish them.
And NMP was always very upset about that. He did not like that
happening at all. Yeah, I know. Also, Malena did do a lot for
him. Like 50/50 was never ever absurd for her to ask for because
she actually did do it a lot to help the stream, help the stream
grow.
Right? Help with content. Good to know Nick has a thumb drive
hidden somewhere. Well, I do think he was hiding assets.
I do cuz he talked on stream a couple times about having stocks.
And then when they went to go look at his assets, when he gave
the asset sheet, he had no
no stocks, no assets like that of any kind basically.
And it's like you look and it's like 2018 or 2019 he's talking
about how much Nvidia he's buying. Like quite literally how much
Nvidia he's buying. Like I'm buying tons of Nvidia. And it's
like, "Oh, so you're like a trillionaire now. You're like an
actual trillionaire now, assuming you kept any of it." And
yeah, so we'll see. We'll see what happens. We'll see if that
ever got >> All right. It's time. Let's talk about the
divorce. So, I've been away for quite a while. >> Let's
do it. >> Let me tell you why. At this point the the case
is over. I've been trying to get this divorce settled. It was
a lot longer process than I thought and I haven't talked about
it in any official way up until this point. There's two different
courts. There's the court of public opinion.
That is Reddit, Twitter, all those great and wonderful places.
And then there's the court of law where
>> Oh, also NMP is like the weirdest, most sensitive person
to criticism.
Like I don't think anybody really thought he deserved to not
get anything in his like Like I don't even People were like,
"Oh yeah, this should should be 50/50. Like it just should be
50/50. It'd be really easy to do this."
So, for some reason he
he talks about the court of public opinion and how he gets criticism
and people hate him. I don't even think there's a large contingent
of people who hate this guy. I think he's mostly hallucinated
that. He's like fairly inoffensive to be honest with you. >> I
believe that was the best place to spend most of my time and
focus most of my efforts. After it was settled, then we could
talk about it. We could dispel any rumors or any sort of questions
people had. And that's who this video is for. It's for people
who generally are curious about what happened. I have documents
here in front of me. I'm going to read them as they are. I'm
going to try my best to not have any
I think credible allegations of infidelity against him.
I think that
if there was a situation near the end of their marriage where
they moved to Spain, I think, to take care of Milena's
parent who was sick.
And NMP went to like some Euro
And I think a lot of people do them and I think he I think he
[__] around at that TwitchCon.
I think he met some I I think so, okay?
Getting a little too close to Nora. Yeah, there's the Nora stuff
and
well, uh obviously catchy eventually, too. So >> of my
opinions in here. Some of these things are a bit confusing for
people who don't know lawyer speak. So, I'm going to do my best
to explain these documents in a more casual way. So, hopefully
everyone can understand them. Keep things as plain as I can.
This isn't to inflame the situation or cause any stress to anybody
whatsoever. I just want to speak the truth, finally. So, I want
to do my best to provide an accurate timeline of what happened.
The divorce was filed by Milena in January of 2025. We had split
up the previous year. It was amicable. We tweeted about it on
Twitter. Everyone saw that. And the divorce ended up being officially
filed by her in, like I said, January. I sent Milena a 50/50
offer down the middle in April of that year. She did not accept
it. I did not know what she wanted out of this divorce until
mediation, which was actually in November. And essentially what
she wanted was the same thing she wanted in trial, and that's
what we have here. I warned Milena that trial would be very expensive.
It would cost hundreds of thousands of dollars. But still, we
had to go to trial, and you'll see why. So, bear with me.
I think I'm going to I'm guessing just my guess would be I'm
pretty confident he was hiding assets and that's why they had
to go to trial. And I'm guessing cuz he's making a video and
not
and that he doesn't have like his tail tucked between his legs.
I'm guessing at the trial they couldn't find I I'm guessing they
couldn't find anything,
Yeah, the idea that he was worth 800,000 I do think is a little
silly. Like I think he got very he got in very early in streaming.
I think he got a money manager very early into streaming.
if his money was invested even remotely competently, which I
believe it was,
I'm thinking they got a seven-figure net
>> Let's keep going. We now we are going to go into some
legal documents. What I have here is what they call Milena Medtoy
Palom's first amended disposition of issues. So, this is essentially
what she wanted. So, the first thing that she wanted was to grant
the divorce between the parties on the grounds of insupportability.
This is very important and I'm explaining exactly what that means
right now. In Texas, a divorce can be granted on the grounds
of insupportability, which is the state's no-fault divorce ground.
The Texas Family Code defines insupportability as a conflict
or discord of personalities between the spouses that destroys
legitimate ends of the marriage relationship and prevents any
reasonable expectation
of reconciliation. In
>> practical terms, it means neither spouse has to prove
wrongdoing.
No evidence of adultery, cruelty, >> That's what happened.
And I didn't see him do that little move. >> No evidence
of adultery,
>> cruelty, abandonment, or other fault is required. The
court only needs to find that the marriage has become unworkable
and that reconciliation is not reasonably expected. So, you can
file divorce on other grounds and I'll explain what those are.
Cruelty, you can file for adultery, which didn't happen,
I That's fine.
But is I feel like this is going to I can already see where the
argument's going to go cuz I think she she might have wanted
more money because of the adultery or the possible infidelity
cuz she definitely filed papers saying as much, that she felt
he was he had infidelity going on, right? And he might say, "Well,
if you actually believe there was infidelity happening, why didn't
you file for like at-fault, like the actual at-fault divorce?
That's That's what I think his argument's going to be cuz I think
later she went on to argue that
she did feel he was being um unfaithful, right? I think I think
she argued that in some documents. So, maybe that's going to
be his point is, well, you can't argue that later if you didn't
file for divorce for that reason. But, I don't think that's true
actually. >> of a felony,
abandonment, living apart, etc. She filed on the grounds of insupportability.
Next, award Milena Mitova Palom a disproportionate shares of
the parties estate for the following reasons, including but not
limited to. So, she wanted more than 50/50. Respondent's economic
and financial abuse of the petitioner, respondent's failure to
permit access to the parties community property accounts, including
for purposes of insight and access to such community funds, benefits
the innocent spouse may have derived from continuation
of the marriage, disparity of earning power of the spouses and
their ability to support, earning power, business opportunities,
capacities, and the ability of the spouses, nature of the property
involved in the division, waste, and attorney's fees to be paid.
So, to explain that, the judge, in in order to grant Milena her
disproportionate share, would have to find something that fits
those sort of grounds, any of those bullet points that I read
off.
>> confirmation of Milena Mitova's separate property as
outlined in the attached spreadsheet, meaning that there's an
attached spreadsheet here that has her own property in it. Makes
sense. Next, order Milena Mitova Palom's waste claim for Nicholas
Michael Palom's excessive expenditures. That was
$100,000 they had claimed against me. The next thing she wanted,
and this is one of the reasons why we had to go to trial, order
Milena Mitova Palom's request for post-divorce maintenance for
a period of 5 years from February 1st, 2026 in the amount of
$5,000 a month. So, she wanted me to pay her $5,000 a month for
5 years. We don't even have kids.
>> Dude, it it literally
I mean
Uh he's such an ass already. He's such an ass. You have a business.
You happen to be the face of the business, but she ran that business
with you. Idiots.
She ran that business with you the whole time. How in the world
are you going to pretend that she's not entitled to like like
something like that. Right? Unless you just want to share the
revenue from the channel, right? It's a business you own together.
You want to share the revenue from the channel with her, then
by all means do that instead. And I think this was like basically
one of the reasons as well that he kind of took time off. I'm
not even joking. >> I I do think that I do >> the
biggest one, the most important one, and it's going to take some
time to explain it cuz this is also why we really had to go to
trial. Order Melina Midtoy Pollem be granted a judgment against
Nicholas Michael Pollem with specific language securing
such interest against the shares and stock held by Nicholas Michael
Pollem with his interests in OTK Ventures, OTK Media, and Kings
Gaming Labs Incorporated. So, this is essentially the crux of
the entire trial. I mentioned earlier that Melina wanted a disproportionate
share of the estate. She wanted a 60/40 split of the entire estate,
but it was a little bit more complicated than that. What she
wanted to do essentially was have her 60%
be all cash and my 40% be heavily weighted in my OTK shares.
She wanted about 90% of the cash reserves, plus she wanted me
to pay her this post-divorce maintenance, and my 40% would be
essentially all in my OTK shares, which >> So, while it
coming out in liquid cash, I could understand that being distressing
for him possibly.
The issue for me is you've got a business that she can't really
maintain a stake in. Right? You can just decide to not stream
and crow over.
And so, because you built this business together, I do think
you're essentially paying her out for her share of building that
business with you. Right? So, maybe the 60/40 thing, I don't
know how fair that is. But, the idea that she should be paid
out in in assets that aren't just shares in those same businesses
makes sense to me.
>> You're going. No one really knows what those are worth.
This was the biggest point of contention in the trial for me.
I don't think anyone would have accepted the offer that was presented
in front of them. Essentially, it would drain me to 10% cash
reserves, be in debt a whole bunch of money. So, I would put
a lot of trust in those OTK shares being worth something someday.
So, that is just about half of the document. And I don't know
why I should say this, but now it gets kind of funny, and I'm
going to explain to you why. Up next is a section called income
taxes, and let me read this for you. Order that any refunds received
from the date of marriage through the date of divorce be divided
equally by the parties, with Malena Midtoy being entitled to
50%
and Nicholas Miceli Polom being entitled to 50%. So, if there
was a tax refund, she would get half of it, I would get half.
>> Who's the greedy party? Uh, I don't think either one's
the greedy party. Like, maybe you could argue some people will
feel like, "Oh, she's looking for 60/40, so she's greedy." I
think given the fact that she has no chance of future profit
from the business she helped build, I don't I don't see it that
way, but I also don't know, maybe Nick's like not really doing
so hot, and maybe maybe the business, you know, on his end isn't
looking that good. There should be some negotiation that comes
through that basically says
like, it's just a pretty dispassionate weighing of what the future
potential of the business is versus what it's made up until now.
That's you just want a analysis of those things. Now, if Nick
thinks, you know, he fell off and he's a loser and he's not going
to be able to make any more money, then I could understand him
wanting to just do like a 50/50 split. He wants to keep a lot
of what he's got and give her some way to to garnish his wages
going forward. Right? Okay, that would be fine.
I still don't get how the [__] his net worth is that
low. If something's going on there, man. >> Of it. Makes
sense, right? Order any liability from the date of marriage to
the date of divorce be paid solely by Nicholas Polom. So, if
there was a tax bill, I would have to pay for all of the
Um but if there's a refund, Milania would get half of it.
Order that the parties file separate tax returns and partitions
as January 1st,
>> Oh, also, the other part about this that's really funny,
okay?
It's being filed by like a divorce
Right? I don't even know how much Milania has a state a say in
this. And the divorce attorney might look at this and go, I'm
going to argue for like everything here. Cuz this guy's like
this guy's clearly doing something. I'm going to I'm going to
argue for everything. Everything I could argue for, I'm going
to argue for. That makes sense to me that your first statements
to a judge before you go to what is it, mediation, would be basically
arguing for
maximum
like maximal benefits, right? >> And that each party be
liable for their own respective taxes for 2026 and each awarded
respective returns for 2026.
Makes sense to me. Up next, injunctions. And this is where it
gets a little bit confusing. I'll try my best to explain it for
everyone. Order Nicholas Michael Polom be restrained and enjoined
from making any public statements, whether written, verbal, or
visual, regarding the ongoing litigation and the parties' divorce,
unless mutually agreed upon in writing by the parties and filed
within the court. So, that essentially says that me, and you
notice her name's not there, but me and me alone can't talk about
it. And then the next line is, strictly in the event the court
does not grant the requested permanent injunction. Permanent
injunction. Milena Mitoy Palum requests the court after trial
on the merits to grant the following permanent injunctions enjoying
the parties, their agents, servants, employees, and attorneys.
So, pretty much everyone involved is this is the following injunction.
Directly or indirectly disseminating, publishing, or causing
to be published or directly or indirectly requesting a person
disseminating or publishing any letter, story, statement, correspondence,
description, or dep- >> Mitoy. Yeah, right, right, right.
Mitoy. >> in any kind whatsoever including on any social
media whether fictionalized or not which is or could be reasonably
interpreted to be disparaging, negative, or defamatory in its
description of the other parties personal, professional, private,
or family life including without limitation the business or the
financial affairs of the other party. So, essentially anyone
involved with me whatsoever cannot talk about this divorce. Spoiler,
that did not get granted cuz obviously we're talking about it
now. I'll explain why that didn't get granted because essentially
that's an infringement
>> of the First Amendment? Yeah.
Yeah, that's This is why anytime you want some sort of gag order
on anything, you need to basically narrow it down
A very, very specific kind of speech that harms you in a very,
very specific way and is tailored to like one person. You know
what I mean? You can't say, "Well, actually every every person
associated with you and can't talk about anything to do with
me you or my family or anyone around me forever." Yeah, it's
not going to work, man. Never. Never. >> on my First Amendment
right to the Constitution of the United States of America which
is freedom of speech. Milena Mitoy Palum requests the court order
Nicholas Michael Palum to pay reasonable attorney's fees, expenses,
and costs through trial and appeal and a judgment should be rendered
in favor of Milena Mitoy Palum against Nicholas Michael Palum
and be ordered to pay directly to Milena Mitoy Palum. Milena
Mitoy Palum requests post-judgment interest as allowed by law.
Also, it says Milena Mitoy Palum requests the court deny any
and all of Nicholas Palum's requested relief filed with the court.
So, that's a lot. I'll explain quickly what she wanted. She wanted
a 60/40 split because of her reasons listed. She wanted me to
pay her >> Her reasons listed. I think we had those reasons
listed, right? It was basically
It was I believe it was infidelity.
That like he was basically
like buying lavish gifts for his new girlfriends and that she
felt the 60/40 split was appropriate because of how he was spending
the money.
How he was like buying like expensive bags and I think they they
even might have had examples in there. >> her $5,000 a
month for 5 years. She wanted the majority of my part of the
split to be locked up in my OTK shares. She wanted me not to
be able to talk about the case whatsoever. She wanted the things
about taxes.
She also wanted
uh to pay her lawyer fees. So, what did I want? Let's get into
it. Uh it's not going to be as long as what she wanted. So, we'll
keep it plain as possible. I'll read it as is, just like I did
with hers. Number one, grounds of divorce. Nicholas Michael Palom
request that the court be granted It really is. Only thing that
we agreed upon in the entire case, which is good. It really is.
Next, division of community property. Nicholas Michael Palom
request that the court divide the community state in a manner
that the court deems just and right as provided by law and set
out in exhibit A attached hereto. So, exhibit A is essentially
a exhibit with spreadsheets and it ends up being a 50/50 split
down the middle. Stocks, shares,
cash,
everything. Next, separate property. Nicholas Michael Palom request
that the court confirm and assign his separate property to Nicholas
Michael Palom as set out in the >> He wanted to pay as
little as possible because her or that might be my bias talking.
Well, I think with with Nick, there's something going on here.
We got a YouTube video about how he's got like a trust or something,
right? He had like a trust set up through his parents that he
got money through like early in his life. And I think people
suspect that he always kept his stocks in that trust.
And so like somehow that trust might be protected or shielded
from getting taken in the divorce because it existed before they
were married. I think it's something along those lines for for
Nick, okay? >> Exhibit A attached here to. So my stuff
is my stuff. Um Milena also had her stuff, her stuff is her stuff,
which makes sense to me. Next, waste and reconstitution. Nicholas
Mikalohm requests the court to find that Milena Mikalohm has
committed waste on the community and to reconstitute what ought
be the actual existing value of the estate as a part of the court's
just and right division of the community estate as set out in
exhibit A attached here to. So just the waste claim essentially
she had one against me, so I want against her. I'm not trying
to get into the the gritty details of that. Next, attorney's
fees. Order Milena Mikalohm pay a portion of Nicholas Mikalohm's
attorney fees, expenses, and costs rendering a judgment against
Milena Mikalohm in favor of Kirk & Davis LLP
Like all I see here is both attorneys, both sets of attorneys
essentially just filing for all of the things that they could
file for.
So before mediation
they're just going to say you're you're going to have to take
on some of everything, right? All it should be is you just pull
the assets, you split them down the middle you take an equal
amount of every asset, kind of like what Nick's saying, although
I think he's hiding stuff
And you split them and you go your separate ways. That's all
it should be.
All assets accrued during the marriage go in one pot, split them
in half. Go your separate ways. Boom, done. >> for Nicholas
Mikalohm and order Milena Mikalohm to pay such a judgment directly
to Stephen W. Payne and Kirk & Davis LLP who may enforce
the judgment in attorney's own name with post-judgment interest
as allowed by law. Attorney's fees. And then my last thing that
I asked for, request for Milena Mikalohm, Nicholas Mikalohm requests
that all relief requested by Milena Mikalohm be denied. So essentially
what I'm asking for in this is a clean 50/50
split down the middle, just like I wanted back in April and uh
March of 2025.
>> Now, one thing he's not addressing is I I think
that there was some intimation from Melina's side that they weren't
getting all of his finances. They were not seeing everything.
Like, the financial disclosures were insufficient.
I I want to say I remember that happening. I wonder if he'll
get into >> Five. What we have here is the court's ruling.
This is what everyone's been waiting for, so let's just go ahead
and get right into it. Dear counsel, from January 12th, 2026
to January 13th, 2026, the court presided over this case and
took it under advisement. The ruling of the court is as follows.
Divorce is granted on the grounds of insupportability.
It's good. That's what I wanted, that's what Melina wanted. It's
a no-fault divorce. Next, division of community property, 50%
to Mr. Pahal and 50% to Ms. Pahal with the exception of King's
Gaming Lab, Starforge, ordered to be split 55% to Ms. Pahal and
and 45% to Mr. Pahal, the court finds that the disproportionate
share of those funds are warranted due number one, the disparity
of the earning power, number two, nature of the property involved,
and three, waste. So, let me explain before everyone gets all
excited what that means. I have a very small ownership in Starforge.
She gets 5% more than I do, and if you do the math, it ends up
being about 15K. If you're >> Yeah, I it's funny cuz
those companies are >> Remember during Melina's disposition
of issues, she had asked for a 60/40 split because of things
like economic and financial abuse of the petitioner. She did
not get that. The community estate was essentially just 50/50
split down the middle with the exception of Starforge, which
is about a 15
>> I man.
This is going to be funny. I think she's going to come out with
a different version of this story. If she can come out and do
a different version of the
he might come out looking really bad. Cuz from what I understand,
she had no access to any of their accounts.
He had literally zero access to anything, any bank accounts,
nothing.
And then she also had a hard time getting access to any like
relief funds was what she was saying.
And I wonder if that was just found to not be true cuz the Well,
the court ordered it fixed. So, I'm guessing he fixed it as quickly
as the court ordered it. And then
yeah, the financial disclosures were just nothing. So, I'm
Ah, I'm very very concerned, very interested to see how this
all went
>> $1,000 extra towards Melania. I I I makes sense to me.
I will pro >> If they By the way, if he had to give all
of his financial disclosures and the estate ended up being far
larger, then I'm fine with it being 50/50.
Do you know what I mean? Like I probably would be fine with it
being 50/50 no matter what,
it would only be if he gave the additional financial disclosures.
This guy's really going to court and saying, "We only have an
$800,000 net worth." That's crazy. >> probably earn more
than her going forward, and that seems pretty fair to me. Up
next, and this is very very very important cuz it has to do with
my shares. Nick and NMPLOL are designated as constructive trustee
for Miss Palom's interest. So, what that means, I don't have
to send her my shares, I don't have to send her cash for the
shares. I will hold her shares in my name until they're sold
if and when they're sold. So, that was a big big big deal for
me. Doesn't put me in generational debt, and you know, if they
sell, they sell. >> generational debt Didn't you just say
this was worth 15K, bro? >> So, what that means, I don't
have to send her my shares, I don't have to send her cash for
the shares. I will hold her shares in my name until they're sold
if and when they're sold. So, that was a big big big deal for
me. Doesn't put me in generational debt and >> I don't
think those are those OTK shares worth all that much? Like generational
debt to me is millions.
I think the the Mizkif payout was like
Was it even 300k? And I think OTK was worth far more when Mizkif
got paid out. I'm trying to think I'm trying to think like Mizkif
Mizkif did not get paid out that much, right? We could go look
at his promissory note. I want to say it was like Was it even
300? >> And you know, if they sell, they sell. Up next,
attorney's fees denied. Each party pays their own attorney's
fees. Motion to seal the court records denied. Injunctions
denied. Post-divorce maintenance denied. That means me not being
able to talk about the case was was denied and the $5,000 a month
for 5 years that Malena wanted was also denied. She did not get
that. Each party is to keep credit card in its debt in their
own name. Each party to keep household furnishings in their possession.
So, all the stuff in this house is mine. All the stuff for her
is as hers. Each party to keep their jewelry and personal items.
So, for example, that necklace that I wore I get to keep. Pokémon
card collection to be divided equally. Mr. and Mrs. Pollum to
each keep their own online skins. Magic the Gathering card collection
to be divided equally. THE SUPER >> IT'S BLACK LOTUS'S.
>> 73 BIKE is awarded to Miss Pollum. Each party to keep
ownership of their own social media accounts. 2023 Cadillac Escalade
is awarded to Miss Pollum. 2021 Nissan GTR is awarded to me.
So, that was the court's ruling. To summarize, it was essentially
the same exact offer that I had offered her back in March and
April of 2025 with the exception of the extra 15k. this court
case lasted well over a year. It cost over $400,000
in lawyer fees, expert fees, and in my opinion, most of it was
unnecessary. Um but I I had to go. I had no choice. If I was
to >> So, this cost you guys half of your net
It really half of your net worth for this case to be I I'm telling
you I'm I'm almost positive
that way more assets got dragged into this and he's just not
saying it.
Cuz that again is the last thing I remember is that $800,000
net worth and being like, oh, this guy's just transparently flying
about his about how much money he has. Is it Porsche I'm guessing
it's $400,000 together like the joint costs of that for both
of them was 400k. >> continue to stream through everything,
people would have been harassing me about it the entire time
like they did when I first started. And I do believe that me
not streaming was the quickest way to come to a conclusion with
this divorce. So, there was a lot of rumors and things that kind
of spawned from this case because documents were leaked and people
made up their own theories and ran with them. I could sit here
and diffuse all of them, it'd be pretty easy cuz none of them
were true. But honestly, I got the ruling that I wanted and I'm
not going to do that. I might mention them on the podcast with
Chance where we can >> I think there's going to be like
some financial disclosures in here that are going to get leaked
eventually. I'm I'm pretty confident, man. >> to do it
in less than formal environment. But that's essentially kind
of what happened. That's the story. That's where I've been. You
know, it really does suck that
also I don't know what he's talking about in terms of taking
time off for for like his divorce, why he couldn't stream through
this.
I I quite literally don't know what he's saying. Unless he just
means I didn't feel like streaming, I was depressed, I didn't
want to go be an entertainer while I was depressed.
Unless that's what he means. >> that things ended up this
way with me and Milena. We spent well over 10 years together.
It just ended up being that way. It's It's the road that we had
to walk and it's over. There was a whole bunch of different dramas
and things that happened behind the scenes that people would
find really interesting, but I'm not trying to throw any shade
at anybody or at this point. If I don't have to talk about that,
I won't. Speaking for me emotionally, this whole thing has been
quite stressful. There's been so many things said about me that
just aren't true. It was somewhat exhausting and once I got this
ruling I I I literally broke down and cried. Like I was like
sobbing
tears, you know, that it was >> Dude, I
To be honest, like if he just granted if he'd gone, "Okay, 55/45."
in mediation
wouldn't that have been better even?
I I truly believe based on the stuff that was being asked for
that it like wasn't that crazy. But I think
I think that Milena was also like quite bitter about how
when she needed him he was like traveling and stuff and wouldn't
come and help take care of her family. I think that's I think
she was quite a like frustrated about that is is my read on the
situation.
Right? So it could be that she just wanted to penalize him. You
know what I mean?
Anyway, thanks for watching. >> finally over. This actually
happened back in January when we finally got the ruling. Uh but
you know, lawyer stuff. It took until last month for it to actually
be over. I wish Milena and her family the best. I have no ill
will towards them. Hopefully things go well for them and I'm
just ready to get back to work. I I want to give this another
try see if I can still do it. So that's the summary. Again, if
you have any questions, you know where to find me.
Thanks for watching and
>> There's only one winner when it comes to divorce court.
It's the lawyers. Because they're walking away with $400,000
of me and Milena's money and they could not give two about us.
>> Yeah. That's true. I think the main sticking point was
the five year spousal
Why? That that honestly should be nothing to him.
Like honest the 5-year spousal maintenance is less than the lawyer's
fees, P-Nup. You know that, right? You do that calculation? $5,000
a month for 5 years? It's still 300k. It is still 300k, but it's
not very much to him. I'm just I'm just saying, "Hey, I have
no business knowing any of this, but thank you for sharing. Lawyers
are the real winners here." So, the the split is like 10% Nick,
10% Milena, and 80% lawyers. Omega lol.
That's the thing to me is like I don't believe this, and I believe
that her a a big part of her actually taking this to litigation
was probably to make sure that they were getting all of the financial
disclosures they wanted, right? That was why they wanted, I believe,
an expert to look through his financials, cuz they couldn't understand
like where Where is your money going?
Actually tried to [__] you over completely. Oh, he's
just like making some Oh, man.
Nah, now I want to look further into
Cuz I I think this is just like a total lie. I I actually think
this is like a like a complete lie to me. Where's Henry? Where's
Henry? Is Henry doing a thing on this yet? Henry Resilient, where
you at? Where you at?
>> keeps having to file these motions to compel to get
documents from Nick because he was supposed to turn over all
his financial records on the >> I knew this was what happened.
He's so full of man.
He is so full of
>> the 25th, as it says right here. But the problem is
that didn't happen. >> There's something going on here,
right? There's got to be something else going on here, right?
Dude, he's hiding financial documents, which Milena would be
naturally suspicious of and bring in lawyers. Well, yeah, that's
When he offered the 50/50, he said, "I have $800,000 in net worth,
and you can have 50% of it." And she went, "That's bullshit."